estado de emergencia declarado en ottawa
a medida que las protestas entran en su
segunda semana en la capital canadiense
la ciudad se ha paralizado el alcalde
james watson y se le anunció el domingo
en un comunicado en twitter
hoy 6 de febrero el alcalde jim watson
declara el estado de emergencia en la
ciudad de ottawa debido a las
manifestaciones en curso camiones y
coches bloquearon las carreteras de la
ciudad durante toda la noche con el
sonido de las bocinas sonando sin cesar
las protestas son una respuesta a las
restricciones por el kobe 19 que impiden
a los camioneros superan entre canadá y
eeuu las manifestaciones han atraído a
una gran cantidad de simpatizantes de
todo el país
dejé mi trabajo no espere a que me
despidieran elegí no vacunar mal
creo que todos deberíamos ser personas
libres no quiero vivir en un país
comunista la gente debería poder tomar
su propia decisión vacunarse o no y no
perder su trabajo no perder su casa no
perder sus ingresos solo por la
vacunación
la policía de ottawa va a recibir
refuerzos para hacer frente a los
manifestantes ya que 250 miembros de la
real policía de canadá se han unido a
sus filas según ellos desde el sábado
por la mañana se han puesto 450 multas
principalmente por exceso de ruido y uso
de fuegos artificiales para la fuerza
pública los manifestantes han puesto en
peligro la seguridad ciudadana en
algunos casos